At 9:07 this morning, we
experienced a partial shutdown.
So, it's a cyber attack.
I think I might've found
something.
Saara, one of our work
experience students
found it.
Do we know who's responsible?
Russia. Most likely FSB.
I'd like to know what we could
do to retaliate.
If we attack them again, it's
just an ever-escalating spiral.
Surely it has to stop.
This country has faced an attack
amounting to an act of war.
It is our duty to respond.
I have decided to declare a
state of emergency.
Where's Putin going with this?
He wants to overturn
the world order.
Did we organize that
counterdemonstration?
We organized both of them.
What if the other side
has already predicted
every step you will take?
They hit us again, we
up the stakes another notch.
And before you know it,
we're into a cycle of
escalation and a catastrophic
loss of life.
There's been a massive leak of
data from GCHQ.
This is far worse than
anything by Snowden.
Truth is they've been one step
ahead of us.
Anticipated how we would
react to every stage.
Shut it down.